so you mentioned you started an Esports
agency Yeah well yeah Esports org uh
back in 20
20 right when covered started right yeah
where did that idea come from so back uh
in the World Cup days of fortnight I was
actually playing a bit of competitive
Fortnight uh with a Pro Plan we were
trying to qualify for World Cup and I
really enjoyed like that competitive
Journey
um and I wasn't that good but the player
I was playing with was really good it
was fresh
um I need low-key High key carried me
um sorry this guy's qualified no we got
like sixth you know sixth or seventh in
our best Duos week okay you need to get
first uh to qualify so because yeah not
many spots for Australia but right yeah
I really enjoyed the competitive journey
and I just liked being involved in just
competitive Fortnight and so yeah
Australia doesn't have much of a scene
for Esports so I just wanted to to get
behind it and yeah really start start
making content for a competitive right
in fortnite was uh yeah definitely a big
drive for me and just bringing people
together in Australia right was it more
to like grow the Australian kind of like
East full scene or because like a big
thing is that starting an Esports
organization uh worst Financial thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah how the hell's that been man yeah
hey look hey look what's the name of
like uh moisten Ludwig burning money
over fire yeah yeah pretty accurate
um yeah look it's uh it's a challenge
and that's probably why I like it
because it's like
uh it's the first business I've ever
done or business adventure that just
loses money and it's like right
it's like fundamentally that's like to
me it's like well this is a failure
right because it doesn't make money but
it's like it's not about money it's
about honestly just bringing people
together making content because it's
more than just Esports it's it's a
Content Journey
um we do like a lot of IRL stuff a lot
of fortnite stuff
we have a rocket League team as well so
we do trying to get those boys involved
as well right um sticking in like the
epic games metaverse I suppose as far as
like their titles right
uh but yeah it's just it's fun it's
different it's really challenging but I
think we're making some good moves so
tell me like the entire process about
how what goes behind actually just
making an Esports organization from from
the start okay so yeah like who do you
talk to yeah yeah
and like well this is the other thing as
well as like I think I think it's just
me and moist are like the only ones
playing with their own money yeah I
think like so I think first step for
most people is seek investors yeah I
can't Venture Capital yeah maybe yeah or
toast as well yeah actually yeah yeah no
that's true uh yeah
um but yeah I think it's just honestly
so so step one find money find money
find money find money you want to burn
yeah how much what percentage of what I
have can I own yeah literally yeah well
that's that's there that's the
conversation
um and uh yeah you just start with the
like I have a really good uh kind of
business partner that I've had from like
kind of the start uh his name is Billy
like started off in like kind of very
professional lawyer services so he
helped me out with getting everything
started and brought over kind of my team
from like my editing team and stuff that
it really built from my channel and just
try to like scale it a little bit right
um and then just yeah hiring people and
Contracting players how'd you how'd you
go about like finding players that you
want to contract for your team and your
organization yeah like trolls or no it's
very much just like what did what are
their goals and do they align with ours
right so our goals aren't like our goals
uh I mean we're trying to definitely
this is winning not the goal yeah yeah
no don't be [__]
but that's like I feel like that's kind
of a fallacy is like winning for teams I
feel like is the highest priority right
it's like I get it right you're not
going in to lose yeah you're obviously
trying to win but the top or the top
level they got this money glitch coming
in from somewhere I don't know where it
is but they're spending so much on the
top player so to win it's very expensive
and that's why no one makes any money
yeah right because they're just ego
bowling each other to try and get the
best players so I actually like for me
it's about picking the best talent in
Australia and how we can prop them up to
compete at an international level
because right the meme is Australia goes
overseas we don't win and it's like you
look at League I don't know if you guys
fought any yeah yeah yeah so all my uh
knowledge of Esports come from is
basically like League yeah dissolved
yeah well they got rid of the league oh
yeah yeah because they were like no one
no one's no one's watching no one's
watching and then so there's the time
zone from like a commercial side you're
only putting it out to people who live
in Australia what 30 million yeah so
that's your viewership and do they like
Esports well not really because we don't
win so it's it's kind of this weird
relationship right so I think that's a
big part of it and yeah trying to prop
up those Australian players so that they
can actually compete at the highest
level right um one thing I've always
been curious about is okay you find the
players because you know in the in the
top kind of echelon of whatever game
you're playing there's only a few you
can pick from that are like can perform
at the top level how did you go about
finding coaching
um yeah you know that kind of getting
that environment to really coach them
into a Esports kind of like environment
yeah I've actually been pretty lucky
with that one the coaches is actually
not too hard oh really had some really
good like people in you know fortnite
and Rocket League who have just been
from other organizations and just
getting them involved like no that one's
actually a pretty easy one yeah what do
you think makes a good coach because
it's I've always found it so interesting
because like our coach is doing a panel
on this a dream hack by the way oh
really okay okay awesome I'll [__] go
there yeah I'm not enough I'm qualified
to speak on it but like his his coaching
philosophy this is Gemma the rocket
league coach is yeah he doesn't come
from a much of a gameplay perspective he
comes from more of a mental and like
like uh psychological perspective right
right you know trying to not tilt and
setting up the player is best for those
kind of Rocket league is an interesting
one like it's very tilt-heavy uh right
that kind of specific Esports I would
argue every uh useful way yeah so I've
seen the smash compilation yeah you know
because Rockley doesn't give you much
time to breathe yeah Legend if you die
you have 30 seconds to like compose
yourself and like all right okay I'll
get it back in the game yeah rocket
League's like oh I've just tilted and
we've lost four goals yeah so yeah it's
a fun one though I really like rocket
League because I think anybody can
understand what's going on yeah right
that's why I love it that's what I love
about the fighting game Community which
is like obviously fighting games people
will tell but that's part of like the
community right it's it's the soul they
embrace it you know that's that's the
best part of it yeah I'm curious
um from like the Esports uh perspective
of
like let's say you have
um like legalization jib 10 teams right
who compete every every week whatever
you know where do you have to be on that
like in that top ten for your team to be
kind of breaking even or making money
because and I imagine the problem
balloons even more so with like fortnite
or Apex when there's like you know
there's so many people right because at
least in league right maybe there's 50
people total you know Apex maybe there's
you know 180 people you have to kind of
get to that level where somehow everyone
can make just enough to survive yeah and
I thought like what does it look like
like if if we're in a game of fortnite
which I don't know how many people are
in a fortnight game 100
like yeah like okay let's say we're in a
pro fortnite match right yeah how many
of that hundred are living off of
playing it professionally and how many
of them have to do other stuff in that
spare time I I saw an article on this
depends on the region uh in Australia I
don't like like five percent even then
like the prize pool they really nerfed
it off the World Cup like it's gone down
ever since right
um yeah and that's why I honestly I
don't think you could have learned from
a pure competitive standpoint that's why
we try to really get the players
involved with content because that
that's how you make it that's that's
what you pitch I know it's like so kind
of like over said at this point of like
oh
my content yeah it's like turning you
know if you have like a Michael Jordan
right you're like hey you should do
Space Jam you should yeah you should do
it's like hey this is how you should
stream I don't want to stream more stuff
yeah like diversify while you're like I
guess name value is like at its highest
right just to make sure to be like all
right yeah you know you can make any
money in other revenues just in case you
[__] fall Cliff skill wise and you
know you're not winning these games or
whatever right but it's a hard
conversation to have with them because
like their their goal is just win yeah
it's not about like you know if I put on
a stream I play worse so I don't stream
and like that's a hard you know chat
about out of players because I'm like
I'd kill to have your skill and be able
to create content and stream like I
would actually kill for that but like
for them it's just like
got thorough last week and we're looking
for forest and it's like I'm you know
that's part of our agenda too we want to
win too so it's like yeah I'm just yeah
more trying to preach that kind of
stability because like Esports is very
Cutthroat it is it is like okay like in
your experience even if any Esports
organization was consistently winning
and that's all they were doing is that
still enough to like is the prize pool
enough to make them a profitable
business or something that can break
even even yeah because even that's a
weird one like I I for me it's like do
people care about the org like that
that's my biggest goal it's like I don't
really care about winning it like going
back to that yeah I mean great we want
to win we want to build a story don't
get me wrong
um and we're you know we're working
towards that and because just because
you can really use that win with a story
to create a reason for people to care
yeah
um but I think that's where like a lot
of you know
these orgs go for just that winning and
it's like oh we won okay cool yeah I
might get a few Partnerships out of that
like I'm sure everyone loves being with
the winning team
um but I think if you're not able to
tell the story as well then it gets a
bit rough and I think G2 would be a good
example of a team that does that yeah
um like really tells the story and wins
well they've all they have a huge
content Focus yeah they just aren't
doing it they're like well we'll always
have a crew yeah and we'll always film
stuff I think that's but also at least
for that League team they have quite a
lot of characters they're pretty pretty
engaging and yeah yeah well I think from
like a spectator like kind of like
Viewpoint
um obviously like winning is the easiest
way to get someone invested in your team
because obviously there are a lot of
people who just like cheering for a team
that wins yeah yeah uh but saying this
as like saying this as an Arsenal fan
who got in uh back back in the back in
the good old days and now is like a kind
of like a G2 fan uh for lead I'm a
YouTube fan too yeah
[Applause]
um but one thing that really drew me
towards both of these teams
um before the winning was just having
this really exciting playstyle or just
like having being like excited every
time to see them play because they had
like a really kind of different play
style as well so even if you're just
doing something exciting in the game uh
aside from just making content as well
uh because from my perspective
I started watching that content after I
saw the exciting things that they were
doing in game so I was like [__] I want
to want to check these guys out and now
and then after that was did I become a
fan did you do you have like a kind of
like a
let's say like a strategy to try and get
people invested in your organization
yeah and I mean it it definitely is
mainly around that content Focus like I
mean for our Channel on on power we
definitely try to involve as much around
the community and the content creators
within Australia yeah
um to try and very much get people on
board so that when they see us in a
rocket League game or when they see us
in a fortnight it's like oh these guys
create great content and that's why I
want to get behind them yeah
um that that is the strategy for us at
the moment I would say do you guys have
a Content house or like no so we've a
Powerhouse that's literally what it was
called it was called a Powerhouse house
we did it for like one month in Sydney
and we had our Pro players come play on
zero pain compete in the finals yeah um
and then we just filmed a bunch of
content it was a great uh kind of test
yeah to see if it would work and the
videos did really well
um competitive players I think we got a
top five in there
um and that was a good test so now we're
actually building a studio in Melbourne
um which hopefully opens up in like a
couple months and that'll be the next
big kind of investment from us to really
have creative people there I won't be
more so for the players be more so for
the team and the content yeah I mean a
lot of the Orcs are focusing on you know
like merchandise and apparel like
building kind of some form of like
turning it into engagement yeah brand
and loyalty in the in the brand which
makes sense right because YouTubers is
one of the biggest ways they make money
is much yeah it's one of the best
margins in terms of uh you know what the
viewer gets something and they get to
support you so it's it's a good good way
have gone about it but I wonder wonder
how long it'll keep being like that I
wonder yeah like how involved are you in
terms of like bringing your own personal
branding of like your you know content
creator YouTube kind of side of things
into this Esports organization because I
feel like you guys like you and moist
and Ludwig and toast have a inherent
advantage in that you already have a lot
of people invested in you as a person uh
so bringing that kind of like brand
power to your organization means it's an
easy way to kind of like create people
who are invested in your uh yeah team
100 and it's like kind of like the story
already started 10 years ago and like
this is like the the end of it like or I
suppose the current stage of it in the
organization
um yeah it's definitely bringing a lot
of that branding like I came from a full
content creator perspective I was like
the only way we're even gonna get close
to profitable is just making content so
let's just start there and yeah work off
players who have you know I suppose I
can't even say with you to like more of
a personality yeah and you know if they
win that's great too like yeah love that
that's and we've got a few of those guys
they're great characters and just really
want to get involved in content but also
put in hard work at being the best of
their game is it ever a question of you
know can can the the Esports agency
that's like like you mentioned like
Maurice or whatever
can can that a can that org ever Eclipse
your own kind of influence and following
or something that's always in the shadow
of I I would say it's probably above
mine right now really be honest yeah
well and that's nice well and it's not
even because that's because many my
numbers have dropped
look but that's the thing is that like I
I run power I don't have like a CEO I
looked at it and they were all like hey
Foreigner K year and I was like hey I'll
do it myself and then which is probably
dumb in hindsight because like I've
definitely sacrificed a lot of time on
my own channel um because this has been
my main priority right but also I think
it's whatever you enjoy doing yeah if
that's something that is more rewarding
for you and with your current stage of
life then like yeah like you know how to
make videos if you want to go back you
could you could easily start that grind
and then get back into it I think yeah
and I get tempted a lot and I'm like I'm
taking a few months off like I think I
was telling you guys about traveling
like gonna travel the next two months
and just focus on Power and just kind of
put my channel to the back for a bit and
then maybe come back to the studio in
Melbourne and maybe re-jig up my channel
again but at the moment yeah it's my
number one priorities is power because I
think winning with the team is way
cooler than winning by yourself yeah and
that's what the channel was for 10 years
just doing well but it's like
you know you you know party with your
other content creators but it's like
imagine parting with the team yeah
that's just so much cooler and so much
more rewarding for sure could you just
say it's the friends we made in life
it's not about winning we're a family we
take care of each other let's sound some
anime [__] right here yeah it's very
animated yeah I didn't ask and I should
have asked this what games did is your
old computer yeah so it's it's fortnite
we started there okay
um and then rocket League
uh which we actually we were the first
Australian team to ever sweep an N A
team in rocket League earlier this year
so I consider that a huge W for us D2 as
well by the way
yeah we love that one we love that uh
and then yeah fortnite we've got uh six
players uh one of which got top five at
dreamhack San Diego
um and he's gone to gamers8 for that big
two million dollar tournament uh later
this year [__] yeah I know yeah no
um I suppose I mean I think a similar or
example but we don't take any prize
money like that's kind of theirs and we
just help build everything else around
it yeah yeah yeah um which I think is
definitely probably the better way of
doing it much more sense yeah how's it
feel seeing your team compete so good
like okay so here's the thing have you
guys watched like moist rocket League
watch parties yeah yeah they're so good
like
yes
yes oh baby so like I watch him right
and he's like I was back in the spring
major last year we were competing and I
was streaming hours on YouTube but we
only made it past one round and it was
depressing because it was like zero
three zero three were out and it was
like [__] um and then I'm I'm sitting
there living through Charlie watching
his team win I'm like [__] man I want
that song and they want it and then they
won it I was like [__] man I feel so
good for him right now that like I've
done on the opposite spectrum of like
stream my team just getting absolutely
rinsed by face plan and just another
team and it's just like I think I've
watched Charlie his team lose it's like
it's depressing it's depressing yeah but
also that's that's the journey but and
it's also the content yeah right like
you're getting depressed they're loving
watching your pain I saw a lot of just
[__] like looking so defeated when
his team lost it was kind of fun yeah
because it's like it's it's like you
said like you see at the highs you get
the lows and that's what makes it great
yeah you see a man who's invested like
let me end and emotion yeah yeah it's
like if you watched Your Arsenal but
every time Arsenal lost you would lose
50k
it's so much more fun to watch yeah
it's a deeper level in the game it's
like higher Stakes because it's not even
money it's also time yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah no it's like the next
level of sports betting like it's like
it's like I know Sports but I make my
own Esports team but also it's kind of
five head because they're just they're
buying essentially just guaranteed
content for themselves yeah yeah because
you get that every single week or
whatever they're playing you get to
stream it and you get to then make money
off of those streams yeah it's good in
the content calendar it's like you know
for streamers specifically as well like
I am not much of a streamer like I
started making YouTube content but I did
do like a two-year uh YouTube deal
streaming a while back and that was
where I really got into streaming and
it was interesting to learn like yeah
not into the stream because you you got
the YouTube deal as like the first wave
yeah we were on the first wave of it
back in the day uh that when mixer was
really starting to pipe up and makes
your sign ninja and then it first
streamer War started and it cool and
that's actually kind of back now kick
yes it's bad for a couple Rumblings
going on
I love twitch